nous nous retrouvons aujourd'hui pour
l'examen de de deux textes mais nous
allons commencer par une proposition de
résolution européenne relative à
l'importante question du glyphosate et
notre collègue Delphine bateau à mes
côté aujourd'hui nouvellement membre de
notre commission pour cette occasion va
rapporter le texte dont est à l'origine
tendant à prescrire le non
renouvellement de l'autorisation du
glyphosate au sein de l'Union
européenne chers collègues madame la
députée je vous laisse tout de suite la
parole
merci monsieur le Président et d'abord
merci de m'accueillir dans votre
lumineuse commission des Affaires
européenne et merci d'avoir permis
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour de cette
proposition de résolution dans un délai
compatible avec la discussion en cours
au niveau européen je voudrais remercier
aussi Monsieur Christophe lesco chef du
secrétariat et Madame Tifen cogier
administratrice qui a rejoint votre
commission dont c'est donc le premier le
premier texte et je voudrais remercier
aussi tous les collègues de différents
groupes qui se sont associés au dépôt de
cette proposition de résolution chers
collègues l'Union européenne doit se
prononcer de façon
imminente sur une nouvelle autorisation
du glyphosate chacune et chacun se
souvient des conditions dans lesquelles
la France c'était à juste titre opposé
et avait voté contre le renouvellement
de autorisation de cette substance en
2017 ce contexte c'était c'était à la
fois un doute sérieux et de vives
inquiétudes sur le plan scientifique
concernant les conséquences du
glyphosate pour la santé humaine suite à
la décision du Centre international de
recherche sur le cancer fondé par le
général de Gaulle et qui fait référence
internationale incontesté en matière de
substances cancérogène de classer le
glyphosate en mars 2015 comme
cancérogène probable qualification qui
n'a pas été retenue ni reconnue par
l'fsa et les cas ensuite un problème
démocratique évident lié à la découverte
des Monsanto papers sur les stratégies
d'influence de la firme concernée
rachetée en 2017 par Bayer et la
découverte que des pans entiers du
rapport d'évaluation du BFR pour le
compte de l'EFSA n'était autre que des
copierscollées des rapports de
montsantau cette situation et notamment
la divergence entre les instituts
scientifiques académiques et les agences
réglementaires auraiit dû alimenter un
débat démocratique légitime et
approfondi et déboucher sur une refonte
profonde de la procédure d'évaluation
des pesticides il n'en a rien été les
recommandations de notre assemblée au
travers du rapport remarquable de
l'opesque de mai 2019 de nos collègues
Philippe Bolot et
Anne gen tête euh n'ont pas euh provoqué
de refonte du système
le débat sur l'autorisation de la
substance glyphosate revient aujourd'hui
dans des conditions qui sont en tout
point comparables à celles de 2017 il y
a néanmoins des éléments nouveaux sur le
plan scientifique en ce qui concerne les
conséquences du glyphosate pour la santé
humaine le rapport de l'incerme de juin
2021 qui fait autorité sur le sujet des
impacts des pesticides sur la santé
humaine a confirmé les inquiétudes le
niveau de présomption d'un lien entre le
glyphosate et un certain type de cancer
le lymphome nonotchkinien pour les
expositions professionnel a été relevé
de faible à moyen l'incerme parlant à ce
sujet d'une association significative
l'incerme a aussi mis en évidence des
dommages génotoxiques l'induction d'un
stress oxydant qui participe aux
pathologies
neurodégénérative des propriétés de
perturbation endocrinienne au sujet des
lincerme soulligne que le fait que la
polémique se centre sur le caractère
cancérogène du glyphosate ne doit pas
occulter d'autres effets sanitaires
importants dont la perturbation
endocrinienne une toxicité mitocondriale
un mode d'action épigénétique du
glyphosate observé dans cinq études des
effets sur le microbiote sur la base
d'études dont l'EFSA n'a pas tenu compte
des effets neurotoxiques qui ont été
confirmés par une récente étude aux
États-Unis par ailleurs comme vous le
savez le fond d'indemnisation des
victimes des pesticides a reconnu il y a
1 an une possible un possible lien de
causalité entre les malformations de Tho
gratalou et
l'utilisation du glyphosate par sa mère
lorsqu'elle était enceinte d'autre part
alors qu'en 2017 le débat portait
seulement sur les conséquences sur la
santé humaine les effets désastreux du
glyphosate pour la biodiversité sont
désormais au centre de
l'attention l'élimination de la flore
par le glyphosate qui est un herbicide a
des conséquences directes sur les
insectes et est donc une des causes de
l'effondrement des populations
d'insectes
supposé sont aussi relevés un risque
élevé pour les petits mammifères
herbivores qui est reconnu par l'fsa
elle-même une toxicité chronique pour
les espèces aquatiques la contamination
généralisée des masses d'eau la
pollution massive des sols avec des
effets négatifs sur les ver ver de terre
verre de terre dont vous savez que la
présence augmente de 25 à 30 % la
productivité végétale par le rôle qu'il
joue dans la décomposition de la matière
organique et la fertilité des sols et
enfin un risque pour les
pollinisateurs sur une base scientifique
toutes les raisons de voter contre le
renouvellement du glyphosate sont donc
confirmé sur le plan économique le coût
des bénéfices de son utilisation est
inférieur au coût de ces conséquences
qui sont de 2,3 milliards d'euros par an
les alternatives économiques en terme de
pratique agronomique pardon excusez-moi
en terme de pratique agricole existe
même si elle nécessite un très fort
accompagnement des agricultrices et des
agriculteurs sur le plan juridique enfin
la jurisprudence de la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne du 19 janvier 2023
concernant les néonicotinoïdes à une
portée beaucoup plus générale et
souligne que la protection de la santé
et de la biodiversité doivent primer
dans les décisions sur la productivité
végétale la proposition de résolution
que j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
salue le vote de la France en 2017 et
invite le gouvernement à renouveler son
opposition à l'autorisation du
glyphosate la proposition de la
Commission européenne actuellement en
débat n'est pas acceptable elle propose
une nouvelle homologation pour une durée
de 10 ans et donc donc pour une période
allant bien au-delà de l'objectif 2030
de diminution importante des pesticides
dans l'Union européenne et ce elle le
propose 10 ans donc pour tous les usages
agricoles cette proposition de la
Commission européenne repose sur une
évaluation de l'fsa dont les bases n'ont
pas été fondamentalement modifiées et
alors que l'EFSA estime elle-même que
les données prises en compte sont
lacunaires en ce qui concerne la
biodiversité mais aussi concernant des
effets sur la santé humaine et notamment
le microbiote intestinal ou des effets
neurotoxiques enfin cette proposition de
la Commission européenne renvoie aux
États-membres et donc à l'aval le soin
de prendre en compte ces préoccupations
scientifiques dans la délivrance des
autorisations de mise sur le marché des
produits à base de glyphosate autrement
dit cette proposition de la Commission
européenne organise un statut du
glyphosate à la carte selon les
États-membres selon ce dont nous ne
voulons pas le débat aujourd'hui
dans cette commission n'est pas de
refaire le débat de
2018 sur le le une interdiction ou pas
française de la substance mais bien sur
la décision qui doit être prise de façon
harmonisée à l'échelle européenne le 13
octobre dernier lors de la réunion du du
scopaf aucune majorité qualifiée n'a été
trouvée autour de la proposition de la
Commission européenne neuf États-membres
ont voté contre ou se sont abstenu
notamment la France et l'Allemagne on se
souvient que c'est l'Allemagne qui en
2017 avait fait basculer la décision en
faveur de la réautorisation un comité
d'appel est désormais convoqué pour le
16 novembre c'est dans ce contexte que
la résolution qui vous est présentée
invite la France à voter contre le
renouvellement de l'autorisation du
glyphosate et à se mobiliser afin que le
glyphosate soit interdit dans toute
l'Union européenne et qu'un plan de
sortie soit mis en en œuvre je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
rapporteur j'en viens tout de suite aux
orateurs de groupe pour une durée de 3
minutes en commençant par le groupe
Renaissance et Jean-Luc
fugit merci monsieur le Président merci
de m'accueillir pour pour cette séance
donc le sujet du glyphosate est très
sensible et a donné lieu à de riches
débats donc fin 2017 à l'occasion du
précédent vote sur la réautorisation de
cette molécule le sujet est revenu dans
le débat public en France lors du
travail de notre assemblée sur la loi
ditgalim en 2018 le gouvernement alors
en place a annoncé vouloir mettre tout
en œuvre pour assurer l'interdiction des
principaux usages du glyphosate en
2021 dans cette optique une mission
d'information parlementaire sur le suivi
de la stratégie de sortie du glyphosate
a été lancé fin septembre 2018 mission
présidée par notre collègue Julien div
et dont les corapporteurs étaient
Jean-Baptiste Morau et moi-même je vous
dis tout ceci pour la transparence dès
le départ la mission a choisi d'avoir
une approche scientifique et
privilégiant la conf iance et non la
défiance envers les agriculteurs à qui
je veux rendre hommage pour la qualité
de leur travail 2 ans plus tard dans
notre rapport final nous avons pu rendre
compte des évolutions observver oui nos
agriculteurs utilisent progressivement
moins de produits phytosanitaires et oui
ils utilisent moins de glyphosate nous
avons noté que sous l'impulsion de la
stratégie gouvernementale laness n'a pas
renouvelé les AMM autorisation de mise
le marché des usages pour lesquels il
existe des alternatives d'usage courant
sans inconvénients pratiqu et économique
majeur concrètement on utilise plus
depuis 2021 en France de glyphosate
entre les rands de vignes ou d'arbres
frutiers on utilise plus de glyphosate
en grande culture lorsque la parcelle a
été labourée ces interdictions sont
d'ailleurs traduites par une baisse
utilisation de l'ordre de 30 %. en
parallèle depuis 2021 plus de moyens ont
été donnés à la recherche d'alternative
un soutien financier via un crédit
d'impôt est apporté aux exploitations
qui renoncent à l'usage du glyphosate
chers collègues ayons bien à l'esprit
que ce passé du glyphosate n'est pas
aisé l'exemple de l'agriculture de
conservation des sols montre que ce
passé de glyphosate peut parfois être
contreproductif sur le plan
environnemental en terme de biodiversité
et d'émission de CO2 alors aujourd'hui
quelle est la situation comme vous le
savez les travaux d'évaluation se sont
poursuivis en Europe pour mieux
connaître l'impact des usage du
glyphosate l'Agence européenne des
produits chimiques qui étudie le danger
des molécules a conclu à l'absence
cancérogène mutagène et l'fsa qui étudie
les risques associés à l'exposition dit
ne pas avoir identifié de domaines de
préoccupation critique ne s'opposant pas
ainsi un renouvellement de l'apobation
de cette mollécule toutefois l'fsa
soulligne soyons transparents les
lacunes d'évaluation des risques sur la
biodiversité au regarde toutes les
données dont nous disposons notre groupe
se félicite du recent rejet récent rejet
de la proposition de la Commission
européenne d'autorisé 10 an de plus le
glyphosate sans condition de restriction
nous préférons la cohérence et
l'exigence que le gouvernement porte
depuis 2018 on restreint les usages là
où il y a des alternatives non chimiques
et on amplifie la recherche pour
développer ces alternatives nous pensons
nécessaire que la France exige des
autres pays européen un engagement à
restreindre les usages là où il y a une
alternative et nous pensons que dans ces
conditions la durée de renouveau
nouvellement pourrait elle aussi être
discuté en revanche nous ne sommes pas
favorables à l'adoption de cette
proposition de résolution car nous
refusons de laisser certains
agriculteurs sans solution c'est aussi
pour nous une question de responsabilité
politique merci beaucoup j'en viens au
groupe rassemblement national à pieric
berartelo pour 3 minutes merci monsieur
le Président mes chers collègues après
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes pour
les producteurs de betterave après
l'interdiction du banfleuraline pour les
producteurs
l'Union européenne pourrait une fois de
plus mettre en péril des secteurs
entiers de notre agriculture avec une
décision complètement infondé la
propagande écologiste a bien préparé le
terrain puisqu'il y avait aujourd'hui
une conviction intime pour la majorité
de la population que le glyphosate
serait hautement cancérigène et que donc
son interdiction doit être prononcée or
ce n'est ni l'AV de l'Agence européenne
des produits chimiques ni de l'Agence
française de sécurité alimentaire ni de
l'Institut fédéral allemand des
évaluation des risques ni de l'agence
américaine de protection de
l'environnement et ni même de l'Agence
japonaise de sécurité alimentaire qui
ont tous conclu que le niveau de risque
ne justifie pas l'interdiction de la
substance c'est d'ailleurs la position
également partagé par le Président de la
République qui déclara en 2018
qu'interdire complètement le glyphosate
reviendrait à tuer complètement
certaines filières avant de revenir sur
sa promesse de 2017 qui visait à
interdire l'usage du glyphosate d'ici
2021 et puisqu'il faut tout de même être
prudent son utilisation est déjà
extrêmement contrôlée en France l'usage
du glyphosate est réservé aux seuls
agriculteurs dans des dosages stricts et
cela parce que nous n'avons pas
d'alternative réaliste à proposer aux
producteur tout comme avec les
néonicotinoïdes ou le B banfluraline
interdire le glyphosate par précaution
serait encore une fois condamné à mort
nos agriculteurs notre position est
rationnelle Pr Dante et éloigné de toute
idéologie tant que nous n'avons pas
d'alternative réaliste pour nos
agriculteurs et puisque les risques ne
sont pas avérés nous refusons d'être les
bourreaux de l'agriculture française
prudence oui mais pour les agriculteurs
c'est pourquoi nous plaidons pour une
autorisation limitée dans le temps soit
5 ou 7 ans le temps de trouver un
produit de substitution il n'est pas
question ici de donner un blanc sein au
glyphosate mais bien de ne pas prendre
une décision hative qui tuerait ce qui
reste de notre agriculture et qui
livrerait notre souveraineté alimentaire
à des concurrences qui eux utiliserai ce
produit je vous
remercie merci beaucoup pour le groupe
de la France insoumise natthalie OL et
pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le
Président la France avait voté contre
l'autorisation de renouvellement du
glyphosate en 2017 à peine 2 ans plus
tard rétropédalage d'Emmanuel Macron
hier la commission envie du Parlement
européen a rejeté l'objection au
renouvellement du glyphosate notamment à
cause de l'abstention des macronistes et
du RN à la France insoumise nous nous
sommes engagés à supprimer l'utilisation
du glyphosate dans l'agriculture d'abord
pour ses effets sur la santé l'incerme
et l'OMS qui sont de des organismes
sérieux ont mis en évidence la
génotoxicité donc la toxicité pour l'ADN
la neurotoxicité la toxicité pour le
cerveau la reprotoxicité toxicité pour
la reproduction les effets sur les
effets de perturbation endocrinienne ou
encore la mytotoxicité la toxicité pour
la respiration cellulaire on peut
ajouter la toxicité pour le microbiote
du glyphosate et les effets
cancérogènes également ont été prouvés
ont été montrés les effets néfastes sur
l'environnement nombreux sont les
insectes les animaux les
micro-organismes et autres plantes qui
peuvent être exposées à ces herbicides
par exemple lorsque des insectes volent
dans la zone des pendages lorsque ces
organismes mangent les plantes traitées
ou des proies qui ont elles-mêmes in
gérer les plantes traitées lorsque le
glyphosate est épendu dans des zones
rurales ou urbaines puis les civé par la
pluie et se retrouve dans les nappes
d'eau souterraines les rivières et les
eaux côtières et puis il y a là un enjeu
démocratique la Commission européenne a
proposé aux étatsmembres de réautoriser
le glyphosate sur la fois de l'expertise
opaque rendu par les deux agences
réglementaires de l'Union européenne
l'Autorité européenne de sécurité des
aliments et l'Agence européenne des
produits chimiques qui compose ces
comités qui contrôle leur action le
Parlement européen n'a aucun contrôle
réel sur cette comitologie et les
parlements nationaux non plus alors que
ces comités opaque impose des décisions
néfastes pour la santé et pour
l'environnement nous regrettons à la
France insoumise le retard qui a été
acté encore une fois hier par le
Parlement européen et nous nous
engageons à nouveau à supprimer le
glyphosate merci beaucoup pour le groupe
des Républicains pour 3 minutes
Pierre-Henri duumont merci Monsieur le
le président merci madame le rapporteur
pour vos explications évidemment
glyphosate c'est une question sensible
qui est loin de faire consensus on l'a
vu au sein de notre assemblée au sein de
la communauté même
scientifique c'est aussi quelque chose
qui peut être instrumentalisé par les
défenseurs ou les détracteurs du
glyphosate et on l'a vu avec les
5400 pisseurs de glyphosate dont les
plaintes ont été classées sans suite
malgré le tapage médiatique qu'il avait
eu lieu autour de cela et donc il est
nécessaire d'être prudent la réalité
c'est qu'il nexiste pas aujourd'hui de
substitut au glyphosate malgré la
recherche et les fonds qui ont été
abondés à la recherche la réalité
également c'est que plus que d'interdire
il s'agirait de limiter l'utilisation du
glyphosate ça a déjà été fait en
particulier chez les particuliers dans
certaines exploitations et certains
types de culture et il y a également
l'apport de la technologie moderne
l'apport de la technologie moderne qui
permet grâce au GPS grâce à l'infrarouge
de pouvoir cibler les quelques plantes
qui son sont des mauvaises herbes et qui
mettent en danger la culture des plantes
que nous désirons par exemple le maïs et
qui permet de cibler au centimètres près
et donc de limiter drastiquement de 80 %
sur certaines parcelles l'utilisation du
glyphosate donc il faudra à mon sens
plutôt que d'interdire purement et
simplement l'utilisation du glyphosate
aller vers ces solutions d'une part de
recherche d'un substitut d'autre part
technique sur le matériel agricole même
pour permettre de beaucoup mieux cibler
et d'utiliser je l'ai dit jusqu'à 80 %
moins de glyphosate le 4ème point
également sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est sur la nécessité de ne
pas surtransposer quand arrivera le
moment de la décision au niveau européen
la décision qui est celle qui est prise
pour une raison qui est très simple
l'agriculture c'est un marché qui est un
marché évidemment unique mais c'est une
politique qui est 100 % intégrée une des
rares d'ailleurs politique intégrée au
niveau européen et on peut pas se
retrouver dans une situation où on
instaure une distorsion de concurrence
qui va pénaliser gravement nos
agriculteurs pour des raisons qui sont
des raison de politique intérieure de
faire plaisir par exemple avant une
échéance électorale en espérant récter
récolter quelques voix à tel ou tel pan
de la société tenons-nous en à la
décision qui sera celle des instances
européennes faisons en sorte de ne pas
mettre plus encore en péril nos
agriculteurs faisons en sorte également
de ne pas arriver sur une interdiction
pure et simple immédiate sans solution
technique de rechange qui je l'ai dit
mettra en péril la survie de pas
beaucoup de d'exploitations agricooles
et qui va donc faire peser également un
risque sur la souveraineté alimentaire
de notre pays qui on l'a vu n'est plus
assurée puisque la balance agricole
Française est déficitaire pour la
première fois de son histoire et donc on
peut pas se permettre aujourd'hui de se
remettre dans une situation aussi
dangereuse entre les mains de personnes
qui n'ont pas forcément on a vu que la
guerre en Ukraine l'intérêt de notre
pays à cœur et c'est pour cela madame le
rapporteur monsieur le Président que le
groupe les républicain votera contre
cette proposition de résolution merci
beaucoup la parole est à Sabine ther
pour le groupe démocrate et pour pour 3
minutes merci monsieur le Président euh
alors cette résolution que nous sommes
appelés à examiner propose une
interdiction totale de glyphosate dans
l'Union européenne elle s'inscrit par
contre dans un contexte dans lequel les
États-membres sont encore en discussion
concernant le renouvelement de
l'autorisation de l'usage du glyphosate
sur le territoire européen vous l'avez
dit hier la commission sur
l'environnement la santé publique et la
sécurité alimentaire n'a pas soutenu la
proposition de résolution appelant à
l'interdiction complète utilisation des
glyphosates et la proposition de
rénouvelement d'autorisation des
glyphosates doit encore être votée le 16
novembre devant le Comité d'appel du
scopaf après une absente majorité le 13
octobre alors un accord entre les 27
semble pourôleur introuvable d'un côté
le gluphosat soulève des inquiétudes qui
doivent être entendu quant à ses impacts
sur la santé humaine et sur
l'environnement de l'autre son
utilisation s'est révélée essentielle
dans la production agricole alors S est
crucial que nous travaillons à
l'élaboration d'alternatives saines et
durables il est pas moins crucial de
préserver notre agriculture particul à
un moment où la guerre en Ukraine
impacte fortement la sécurité
alimentaire depuis plusieurs années la
France est engagée avec détermination
dans une voie de réduction de
l'utilisation du glyphosate nous
dépensons 70 à 80 millions d'euros par
an en crédit d'impôt pour ceux qui
limitent leur utilisation du glyphosate
et les ventes de substances cmr1 risque
verrz sont aujourd'hui proche de zéro
avec une diminution de 96 % des usages
par rapport à la période 2015 2017 nous
nous dirigeons vers l'interdiction à
terme du glyphosate mais en attendant et
vu les divergences d'approche des
États-membres ne serait-il pas plus
utile de pousser fortement vers une
harmonisation des conditions
d'utilisation de ce produit sur les
mêmes bases que celle que la France
s'applique à elle-même là le gain
écologique ser rassure là nos
agriculteurs n'auraient plus à à
souffrir d'une concurrence au sein même
de l'Union européenne à laquelle ils ne
peuvent pas répondre les laissant ainsi
dans l'impasse on ne peut nier les
impasses techniques sur le glyphosate
qui demande donc de pouvoir garder
l'usage de sa molécule là où on ne veut
pas pour l'instant sans passé je pense
notamment à l'agriculture de
conservation des sols alors ni la
proposition de la commission ni la
position défendue par la proposition de
résolution neous sont en accord avec la
proposition modérée défendue par le
groupe démocrate et défendu par la
France au niveau européen substituer
l'utilisation du glyphosate partout où
c'est possible et surtout le faire
partout dans l'Union européenne
merci merci beaucoup la parole est à
Henri alfondarry pour le groupe
horizon merci monsieur le
Président vous donc vous proposez donc
une une résolution qui vise purement et
simplement au non renouvellement de
l'autorisation du cliphosate ce qui
laisse peu de possibilité d'amender sauf
à dénaturer totalement ce que vous
proposez pourtant et ça a été dit il y a
un vrai sujet comme le disait Jean-Luc
fugit à à poursuivre la différenciation
des
usages il est clair que en grande
culture il paraît absolument impossible
de s'en passer alors que sur le
maréchage il y a plein de techniques qui
permettent de se passer du clyphosate il
y a et ça vient d'être dit par la par
Sabine til la question de l'évolution
des pratiques
professionnelles l'agriculture de
conservation des sols permet en effet de
d'avoir un meilleur usage du glyphosate
mais surtout et contrairement à ce que
vous disiez il s'agit de préserver les
sols en évitant des labours profonds et
ce sont des techniques qui justement
préservve les verres que nous voulons
avoir et l'ensemble de la biologie du
sol c'est c'est c'est manifeste il y a
il y a plein de gens et et d'agriculture
sur nos territoirees qui mesur ça
puisqu'ils le font depuis longtemps et
ils ont ils ont des taux de de de
présence de micro de microbiologie dans
les sols absolument énorme et par
ailleurs ce sont les mêmes qui au moment
où on veut séquestrer du carbone arrive
à mesurer la séquestration de carbone et
c'est pareil les résultats sont
excellents en disant ça je ne dis pas
que le glyphosate est un est un superbe
produit dont nous souhaitons pas tous
nous passer à terme bien sûr qu'on
trouvera probablement des choses plus
intéressantes mais il s'agit tout
d'abord de regarder quand même comment
on fait évoluer les pratiques comment
les fait évoluer de manière vertueuse
sur les références de ceux qui
travaillent le mieux par ailleurs il
s'agira donc de trouver des vraies
alternatives pour une sortie du
glyphosate permettant un système
agronomique résilient tout en donnant
une économie pérenne aux exploitants car
si si on ne fait pas ça de toute façon
c'est c'est l'ensemble du monde agricole
qui tombera et ça nous aidera ni à
séquestrer du carbone ni à avoir un
environnement qui nous permet d'avancer
sur la la transition écologique et
climatique donc il s'agit de de ne pas
avoir d'idéologie d'autant plus que vous
le savez bien nos processus de
d'homologation de produits sont assez
peu satisfaisants on a encore tout un
tas de produits que pour le coup on sait
pas cancérigène probable mais
cancérigènes certains qui sont autorisés
sur le marché peut-être devrions-nous
commencer par retirer cela et et
vérifier réellement comment on obtient
les homologations puisqu'on a encore
certains principes où il suffit de payer
pour avoir l'homologation ce qui est
quand même pas extrêmement satisfaisant
donc par ailleurs en faisant ça on se
détourne aussi des des vrais vrais
problèmes que sont la sécurisation des
intrans tant au niveau azote que
phosphate et et clairement il y a
l'angle mort de la production agricole
qu le protoxyde d'azote je pense qu'on
on se trompe de priorité et il faut
mieux mieux utiliser le glyphosate que
de le supprimer merci beaucoup la parole
est à Marie pochon pour le groupe des éc
iste pour 3 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Madame la rapporteur chers
collègues j'ai demandé au gouvernement
de prendre les dispositions nécessaires
pour que l'utilisation du glyphosate
soit interdite en France au plus tard
dans 3 ans il y a 6 ans la France votait
contre le renouvellement de
l'autorisation du glyphosate dans
l'Union européenne sans suiver cette
promesse forte du président de la
République 6 ans plus tard ma collègue
Delphine bateau nous propose une PPRE
visant justement à renouveler cette
prise de position et à mettre en place
un plan de sortie àors même où la
Commission européenne souhaite revenir
sur la sortie de ce pesticide pour les
10 ans à venir
cela semble d'une grande évidence et je
pensais que les réactions de mes
collègues seraient évidemment favorabl à
la poursuite de l'action de la France
engagé par la parole présidentielle il y
a 6 ans car il s'agit là de faire suite
aux innombrables études scientifiques
publié depuis lors de donner une
perspective claire aux agriculteur de
notre pays et de faire primer les
objectifs de santé humaine et de
protection du vivant condition de notre
existence tout entière au-dessus
d'intérêt productif pour une agriculture
qui ne se relèvera pas de l'effondrement
de la biodiversité
entre 1990 et 2017 la consommation
mondiale de pesticides a augmenté
d'environ 80 %. la France est sur le
podium des pays européens qui autorisent
le plus de pesticides leur usage y a
augmenté de 25 % entre 2011 et 2018 on
ne compte plus les dégâts engendrés par
le glyphosate plus connu sous le nom de
Roundup produit phare de la firme
Monsanto puis Bayer condamné à verser
des milliards de dollars à plus de
100000 victimes aux États-Unis
contrairement à l'Agence européenne des
produits chimiques linerm et d'autres
agences parlent de lien significatif en
matière de perturbation endocrinienne de
de reprotxicité ou de neurotoxicité
chers collègues la santé des gens et des
agriculteurs doit être notre priorité
par ailleurs ce que nous propose cette
résolution c'est de maintenir une
perspective claire pour le monde
agricole de manière coordonnée à
l'échelle européenne face à des
revirements permanents des politiques
publiques ces allers-retours incessants
ces remises en cause des décisions
prises et des études scientifiques sont
destructeurs pour la planification de la
transition agricole et les agriculteurs
eux-mêmes l'agriculture de demain
nécessite un cap cl clair et ambitieux
pour lui permettre de nourrir la France
et l'Europe quelle est cette pression
folle qui nous fait faire ainsi voltef
chers collègues êtes-vous tributaire de
nos concitoyens européens ou des lobbyes
on dénombre 57 % d'oiseau en moins dans
les milieux agricoles en Europe depuis
40 ans nous allons vers une extinction
totale des insectes pollinisateurs d'ici
la fin du siècle depuis 20 ans du fait
des changements climatiques les
rendements agricoles ont déjà baissé de
plus de 20 % au niveau européen il faut
imaginer les conséquences en chaînes sur
nos sociétés de l'effondrement du vivant
même en matière de souveraineté
alimentaire le sens de l'histoire chers
collègues à ce moment si crucial de
toute notre humanité qui est celui du
défi écologique et de tenir le cap et de
faire preuve de bon sens la France ne
peut pas ne doit pas céderder au lobby
phytosanitaire qui n'ont comme intérêt
que la profitabilité à court terme et en
aucun cas le mieux vivre des
agriculteurs la santé des gens des sols
et des écosystème elle doit choisir
définitivement son son camp celui de
l'intérêt général et du bon sens c'est
ce que nous pouvons faire aujourd'hui au
travers du vote de cette résolution je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Marietta Caraman pour le groupe
socialiste et pour 3 minutes merci
monsieur le Président Madame la la
rapporteur mes chers collègues la
question de la dangerosité donc du
glyphosate et de son interdiction
revient devant notre commission et c'est
un deséserb qu'on l'a été rappelé très
bien ici le plus utilisé en France et
dans le monde et il a été inscrit sur la
liste des substances actives approuvé
par l'Union européenne en 2002 et son
autorisation a été renouvelée en 2017
pour 5 ans lors de ce dernier vote je
tenais quand même à insister pour notre
groupe la France s'était prononcé contre
le renouvellement de l'autorisation du
glyphosate et le 10 mars 2015 le Centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
classait le glyphosate justement comme
cancérogène probable pour l'homme et
ouvrait une controvere durable sur la
dure la sreté du pesticide de synthèse
le plus utilisé en France France et dans
le monde l'autorité européenne
d'ailleurs de sécurité des aliments a
indiqué dans son dernier avis
l'évaluation de l'impact de glyphosate
sous la santé humaine la santé animale
et l'environnement n'a pas identifié
donc de domaines de préoccupation
critique mais de de son côté l'Agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire et de
l'alimentation de l'environnement et du
travail avait été saisi en 2016 pour
évaluer le potentiel cancérigène de la
substance elle avait conclu que le
niveau de preuve de cancérogénosité chez
l'an mal et l'homme est relativement
limité et ne permet pas de proposer un
classement de glyphosate en tant que
cancérogène et avéré ou présumé pour
l'être humain mais selon un grand
quotidien français une partie aussi de
de l'expertise avait disparu il mettait
aussi en avant le choix des questions
posées aux experts et il est important
d'interdire un produit justement lorsque
de forces soupçon de dangerosité existe
l'article 168 du traité de
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
oblige justement celle-ci à assurer un
niveau élevé de protection de la santé
humaine et de plus l'Union dispose de
nombreux leviers pour assurer la
sécurité sanitaire et alimentaire
traités internationaux y compris
commerciaux règles coutumières du droit
international et en l'espèce il existe
une obligation de diligence au terme de
laquelle les États sont tenus de mettre
en œuvre tous les moyens à leur
disposition afin de prévenir les
dommages causés de toute activité placée
sous leur contrôle cela s'impose donc à
la fois à l'Union européenne aux
États-membres et pour l'heure malgré les
doutes forts lacune et cetera l'Union
européenne semble suivre son avis si
j'étais l'Union je prendrai le problème
par l'autre bout nous sommes bien
conscients des enjeux économiques mais
dans le cas de la dangerosité de
produits une étude faite aux États-Unis
a montré que les entreprises
abandonnaient l'utilisation d'un produit
plus rapidement que les autorités
publiques ne le réglementai de peur
justement de procès et de voir les
consommateurs se détourn de leurs
produits aussi les entreprises qui ont
accès à des solutions techniques aux
effets équivalents mais sans danger
doivent aussi pouvoir les mettre en
œuvre selon avec un échéancier de mise
en conformité et par ailleurs et sans
être une spécialiste je n'ai pas trouvé
trace d'un engagement de l'Union
européenne sur un programme de recherche
visant à trouver les substitut sans
risque à ses additif donc nous
effectivement nous soutiendrons cette
résolution pour notre groupe et nous
souhaitons dans la même ligne comme
depuis longtemps dans cette position
contre le glyphosate merci Madame
Caraman on a fini avec les orateurs de
groupe il encore quelques demandes de
prise de parole en commençant par Nicole
lepet pour 2 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues c'est plus une intervention la
résolution glyphosate oui nous devons
sortir de l'usage du glyphosate
cependant revoir en profondeur nos
méthodes de production et l'usage des
pesticides ne révèle pas d'une gestion
de crise mais bien d'une trajectoire et
et ça réclame un temps long et c'est
l'agricultrice qui vous parle un triple
défi se dresse devant nous pour
préserver notre chaîne de valeur
alimentaire et notre environnement
concilier la production agricole et
nourrir de conservation des ressources
naturelles et bien sûr la maîtrise des
coûts pour une pérénité alors cette
réalité s'impose nous devons nous
adapter et revoir nos pratiques cette
transformation voyonsles comme des
leviers de progrès résoudre cette
équation dans un contexte global de
dérèglement Climaque nous engage à
poursuivre des transitions majeures et
assumer collectivement le prix de ces
changements il n'est pas concevable que
seuls les agriculteurs en supportent le
coût social et j'appuie sociétal dans
cette quête de souveraineté
l'agriculture est source de solution il
nous faut prendre nos filières agricoles
ou du moins les rendre plus compétitives
et produire mieux certes nous pour
stopper le glyphosate ayons des
solutions pour assurer notre capacité à
produire mieux et plus pour nourrir les
448 millions d'Européens et juste un mot
sortant d'un rendez-vous à la FAO et
ayons écouté le dernier discours de
Madame Van derlen je reste inquiète sur
la sécurisation de l'approvisionnement
des denrées alimentaire en Europe je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Grégoire de fournass pour 2
minutes
oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président je jeis peut-être plus parler
en tant que que vticulteur que députés
parce que je fais partie des gens qui
sont sur le terrain et qui ont dû mettre
en œuvre les réductions drastiques de de
glyphosate et qui quelquefois se
demandent comment certains certains élus
peuvent tenir des discours très
idéologiques mais finalement très
éloignés de des des des difficultés de
de toutes ces belles idées j'ai entendu
madame la
rapporteur citer un certain nombre
d'études avec des des interprétation je
suis désolé de vous le dire mais qui
sont fausses euh et il y en a une qui
m'a quand même frappé c'est la décision
du fond indnisation des des victimes qui
a été effectivement rendu en en mars
2022 et que vous n'avez apparemment pas
lu parce que cette cette décision ne
fait état de d'aucune étude et et et la
motivation la l'unique phrase de
motivation de cette décision euh est
tout sauf basé sur des des faits
scientifiques en réalité vous vous vous
vous délégitimez des agences
scientifiques qui rendent des rend des
avis sur la base de milliers d'études et
et et vous mettez en avant des avis qui
encore une fois sont très loin de la
science on a parlé tout à l'heure de
l'agriculture de conservation on a eu
dans la commission d'enquête phito qui
se tient en ce moment l'occasion de
pouvoir entendre un un jeune agriculteur
nous parler de de la la richesse des des
vers de terre dans ces dans ces sols
grâce à la culture de conservation et
donc de l'utilisation du du glyphosate
peut-être que Madame pochon aurait pu
entendre cette ce témoignage elle qui
est vice-présidente de la Commission
d'enquête mais qui ne vient quasiment
jamais ce qui ce qui démontre quand même
votre désintérêt prof fond pour les
réalités scientifiques des des des
mesures que par par ailleurs vous portez
et je vourais terminer pour vous dire
pour vous dire quand même
l'abération de de de cette de ces
mesures sur les glyphosat c'est que
certains vticulteurs sont venus à
utiliser le flumioxanine Zazine pardon
qui est un un prélev un antilevé un
prélevé pardon et qui permet donc qui
est une alternative au glyphosate mais
qui est un CMR alors que le glyphosate
ne l''est pas voyez voyez donc
l'abération de ces mesures merci
beaucoup la parole est à gours pour le
groupe des éc logiste pour 2 minutes
tout d'abord je tiens à remercier ma
collègue Delphine bateau pour cette
proposition de résolution européenne que
le groupe écologiste bien naturellement
soutient pleinement et entièrement il
est urgent que le Parlement adopte une
position en faveur du non renouvellement
de l'autorisation de glyphosate au sein
de l'Union européenne pourquoi parce que
ça a été rappelé les glyphosate est un
produit extrêmement nocif et dangereux
pour la santé classé cancérigène
probable par l'OMS depuis 8 ans en
témoigne les nombreuses condamnations de
Montsanto c'est le plus gros scandale
sanitaire de notre siècle autoriser le
glyphosate pour encore 10 ans va
totalement à rebour de l'histoire et il
est urgent d'en interdire l'utilisation
la deuxième raison le glyphosate est
aussi la pierre angulaire d'un système
économique et industriel qui incite et
exhorte à un certain usage du monde et
du vivant et qui rend dépendant nos
agriculteurs et agricultres à
l'agrochimie au lieu d'envisager une
agriculture nourricière de proximité et
qui respecte la biodiversité en France
plus de 60000 exploitations agricoles
pratiquent pourtant déjà des
alternatives non chimiques au glyphosate
3 TR raison le glyphosate c'est un éniè
exemple du manque de vision écologiste
absolument sidérant de notre
gouvernement et de la lâcheté politique
du président de la République qui
renonce à des bataille qui faisait
pourtant partie de son programme en 2017
encore une fois ce gouvernement laisse
les lobis gagn et manifeste son mépris
total pour la santé des agriculteur et
de toutes les personnes exposées au
glyphosate j'en viens à mes questions
l'inerme linra et les autres prestigieux
institut de recherche français ont
conclu unanimement à la nocivité du
glyphosate à ce stade diriez-vous que
notre gouvernement ne fait pas confiance
à ses scientifiques que faut-il de plus
pour que le gouvernement sorte de
l'hypocrisie d'un côté on fait confiance
à la science pour trouver des solutions
technologiques plus tard et de l'autre
pas quand les scientifiques démontrent
que cela est hautement nocif et qu'il
faut l'interdire et puis pouvez-vous
nous éclairer sur le rôle joué par les
lobby pour empêcher l'interdiction du
glyphosate quelle est leur influence
selon vous sur le revirement de position
du Gouvernement sur le glyphosate je
vous remercie merci beaucoup la parole
est à Laurence sedel pour 2 minutes au
nom du groupe Renaissance je peux
l'avoir à nouau merci monsieur le
Président mais chers collègues en 2022
l'Agence européenne des produits
chimiques a réalisé une évaluation des
dangers lioglyphosate elle a conclu que
le glyphosate ne répondait pas au
critères scientifique pour être classé
comme une substance cancérigène mutagène
ou reprotoxique en juillet 2023 l'fsa a
publié une évaluation des risques
associés à l'exposition au glyphosate
sur la santé des humains des animaux et
de l'environnement cette évaluation dit
qu'elle n'a pas identifié des domaines
de préoccupation critiqu je vous invite
tous à écouter les résultats de ces
travaux dans le même temps l'ANS a
conclu à l'impossibilité de substituer
au glyphosate une méthode alternative
non chimique pour la culture de la vigne
notamment dans les parcelles non
mécanisables vigne installé en forte
pente ou en terrasse sol caillouteux
vigne mè de portegreffe le remplacement
du glyphosate sous le rang n'est
également pas possible pour les cultures
buissonnantes petits fruits et noistiers
et les alternatives par déserbage
mécanique et l'enerbement par tonte
présentent des inconvénients majeurs
dans le cadre de la mission
d'information sur le glyphosate don
notre collègue Jean-Luc fugi était cor
rapporteur les surcous annel annuels des
alternatives au déserbages chimiques
pour les productions où elles existent
ont été évaluées ils vont jusqu'à 432 €
par hectare aussi mes questions sont les
suivante que proposez-vous à nos
agriculteurs lorsqu'il n'existe pas
d'alternative au glyphosate et
lorsqu'ils existent des alternatives
elles ont un coût significatif pour les
agriculteurs aussi que proposez-vous
pour la prise en charge de ces coûts
afin de ne laisser aucune exploitation
agricole dans une impasse technique et
ou financière il n'y a rien dans la
résolution sur ces point point c'est
bien dommage et pas du tout à la hauteur
des
enjeux merci je redonne la parole à
Madame osiol au nom du groupe de la
France INSIS comme tous les groupes ont
pu se réexprimer elle prend la une
deuxième fois la parole au nom de son
groupe pour 2 minutes oui merci monsieur
le Président c'est en entendant un petit
peu les les arguments des des défenseurs
autoproclamés des agriculteurs et des
agricultrices c'est pas tant une
question en fait pour Madame bateau que
pour que ceux qui voilà qui qui ont dit
défendre les agriculteurs en disant que
le glyphosate était inévitable et que
c'était un un bienfait pour
l'agriculture que
répondent-t-il à celles et ceux aux
agriculteurs aux agricultrices qui ont
manifesté il y a quelques jours parce
que ce n'est pas vrai qu'il y a un
consensus y compris chez les
agriculteurs que répondent-t-il à
Dominique Marchall céréaliers intoxiqué
aux pesticides qui est exploitant à en
mort et Moselle premier agriculteur dont
le cancer a été reconnu en 2006 comme
maladie professionnelle qui é qui était
chargé de l'épendage des pesticides et
des herbicides sur son exploitation qui
a donc développé un un cancer à l'âge de
44 ans et qui euh euh est vice-président
de l'association phytovictime fondé en
2011 euh et qui reconnaît la
responsabilité de Montsanto dans le
déclenchement de de sa maladie ou encore
à Bernard Morel ancien agriculteur qui
dit lui que et bien c'est comme ça
depuis le début où il était agriculteur
on on faisait avec ses produits
phytosanitaires et que maintenant il est
atteint lui aussi d'une maladie qui a
fait que le nombre de lymphocyt s'est
multiplié dans son corps bref ce n'est
pas vrai que ça protège les agriculteurs
et les agricultrce le les les effets
néfastes c'est sur la santé de tout le
monde et les agriculteurs sont les
premiers exposés madame ool il y a une
dernière prise de parole Sandrine leffer
et puis après sera delelfine de bateau
de vous
répondre merci monsieur le Président
jamais 203 une troisème agricultrice va
vous vous répondre et prendre la parole
chers collègues si je prends la parole
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui c'est pour vous
exprimer ma vive inquiétude concernant
les débats européens autour du
glyphosate après des années de
controversse sanitair et
environnementale nous ne parvenons pas
encore à affirmer une réalité pourtant
démontrée par un corpus scientifique
solide le glyphosate est une substan
cancérigèn proba génotoxique
reprotoxique perturbateur endocrinien
toxique et et neutoxique au-delà de la
santé humaine il affecte aussi les
écosystèmes terrestres et aquatiques si
les institutions sanitaires européennes
ont tant de mal à l'affirmer c'est
qu'elles prennent en considération un
nombre plus restreint d'études notamment
d'origine industrielle contrairement à
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé il
ne s'agit plus aujourd'hui d'un débat
technique mais éthique j'aimerais
aujourd'hui affirmer mon soutien envers
une position diplomatique forte que la
France s'oppose à la réautorisation du
glyphosate à l'échelle européenne sauf
dans des cas de figures très restreint
où aucune alternative économique viable
n'existe nous devons réaliser que sans
écosystème résilient nous perdons tout
je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup madame bateau
vous avez la
parole bien merci chers collègues de de
vos
interventions je vais reprendre par
intervenant un certain nombre de points
qui sont extrêmement
importants
d'abord monsieur Fuji a dit qu'il y
avait moins d'utilisation euh du
glyphosate en agriculture euh en France
euh aucun chiffre public ne permet de
l'étayer nous avons demandé donc je je
je vous indique chers collègues que ce
chiffre de 30 %
neoute madame la rapporteur le chiffre
de 30 % nous avons auditionné pour la
préparation de ce rapport le directeur
de cabinet du ministre de l'Agriculture
nous avons demandé la communication de
ces données qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
publiques elles ne nous ont pas été
transmises d'autre part donc elles sont
peut-être vrai ne le sont peut-être
pas'il plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît on écoute écoute la rapporteur
madameolsur monsieur Bertelot là c'est
tous les groupes écoute la rapporteur
s'il vous plaît qui est la seule à
s'exprimer je
suis je suis rapporteur pour l'Assemblée
nationale je demande la transmission de
chiffre je n'ai pas pu vérifier ce
chiffre alors que je l'ai demandé
d'autre part c'est un point qui est
aussi important à l'échelle européenne
nous venons d'avoir confirmation par la
Représentation permanente de la France
auprès de l'Union européenne qu'il
n'existe aucune donnée publique depuis
2017 sur l'évolution de la consommation
de glyphosate par pays c'est la réponse
officielle qui nous a été communiqué en
fin de matinée et ça pose un vrai
problème de transparence euh donc moi je
veux bien entendre qu'il y aurait eu une
diminution d'usage du glyphosate en
France que celle-ci après avoir
fortement augmenté rejoindrait
actuellement en France grosso modo les
quantités qui étaient utilisé à la fin
des années 2000 c'est-à-dire vers
2009-20 simplement je vous dis je je ces
chiffres ne sont pas dans le rapport
parce que nous les avons demandés et
nous les avons pas obtenus euh d'autre
part chers collègues sur bon nombre de
vos de vos remarques euh pardon mais
l'incerme est un organisme
scientifique qui fait référence de façon
incontestable et non pas les autres
aussi chers collègue l'Assemblée
nationale et le Sénat ont porté un
rapport de l'opesque qui montre tout le
problème de la manière dont les agences
réglementaires évaluent aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de substances en se
basant sur les données des industriells
données qui ne sont pas rendu public et
écartant comme non pertinente ou moins
pertinente les données de la littérature
académique c'est ça la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes c'était déjà la
donnée du problème en 2017 à av par le
fait qu'en plus le rapport de l'fsa
était intégralement un copier-collé de
de des documents de de monsantau mais
donc la situation scientifique est
claire et pour moi sur ce qui concerne
les impacts sur la santé humaine c'est
l'incerme qui fait référence et je ne
crois pas que ça puisse être contesté je
reviendrai tout à l'heure sur la
question des restrictions d'usage qui
ont été évoquées par plusieurs collègues
euh l'intervention du rassemblement
national semblait regretter même
l'interdiction des néonicotinoïdes qui
tuent les
abeilles donc bon c'est un c'est un
point de
vue qui en don sur vos conceptions
relative aux impacts d'un certain nombre
de substances pour la biodiversité et la
santé humaine je remercie madame osuré
de de ses interventions et de son
soutien à la proposition euh monsieur
monsieur
Dumont vous
avez
évoqué un point sur lequel je voulais
revenir qui est un point extrêmement
important vous avez évoqué le fait que
il fallait pas surtransposer qu'il
fallait s'en tenir à la décision de
l'Union européenne ce que je veux bien
expliquer à tout le monde c'est que la
décision qui est en cours à l'échelle
européenne n'est pas
du tout par exemple la logique qui a été
évoquée par un certain nombre de
collègues sur les restrictions d'usage
le ciblage et cetera la décision qui est
en cours et qui est proposée par la
Commission européenne va créer
précisément ce que vous êtes ce que vous
venez de dénoncer c'est-à-dire qu'elle
renvoie aux États-membres le soin dans
les procédures d'homologation à
l'échelle de chaque État membre des
produits composés à base de glyphosate
de REM dié aux lacunes scientifiques
constaté sur certains effets pour la
santé concernant les aspects
neurotoxiques et microbiote intestinale
et de remédier au problèmees d'absence
de méthode d'évaluation harmonisé
concernant les effets directs et
indirects pour la biodiversité autrement
dit le cadre qui est sur la table
aujourd'hui proposé par la Commission
européenne et dont nous souhaitons que
la France vote contre et précisément un
cadre qui va générer la situation que
vous évoquez qui n'est pas souhaitable
de distorsion entre les différents pays
européens je remercie Sabine tiller
d'avoir évoqué le le contexte auquel
j'ajouterai le pacte vert et les
discussions en cours sur le règlement
sûr il est de ce point de vue à mon sens
pas concevable que le glyphosate soit
réautorisé pour 10 ans tandis que
l'orientation générale de d'autres
réglementations en cours de discussion à
l'échelle euh européenne vont dans le
sens au contraire d'une élimination des
substances les plus préoccupantes et
d'une réduction drastique euh des usages
euh de euh 50 % euh vous avez évoqué
aussi
euh l'utilisation du du glyphosate qui
serait euh essentiel en agriculture et
et et à la sécurité alimentaire euh cher
euh et que nous nous dirigerions à terme
vers une interd non pour l'instant ce
qui est sur la table c'est une
réautorisation et aucun horizon de
sortie du glyphosate ou d'interdiction
futur et en ce qui concerne la sécurité
alimentaire je voulais rappeler à
l'ensemble des collègues à quel point
celle-ci dépend de la bonne santé de la
biodiversité que ce soit les vers de
terre ou les pollinisateurs et que donc
d'introduire des des substances qui
provoquent des ravages sur la
biodiversité et une menace lourde pour
la sécurité alimentaire européenne et
mondiale merci à Monsieur alfanderi euh
d'avoir rappelé les failles qui existent
dans les procédures européennes
actuelles d'évaluation euh plusieurs
d'entre vous on ont évoqué le cas
particulier de l'agriculture de
conservation des sols je veux rappeler à
tout le monde que les pratiques qui
concernent 4 % de la surface agricole
utile en France ne peuvent servir de
prétexte à justifier une autorisation
d'une substance pour 96 % de la surface
utile
restante d'autre part il faut par
rapport à vos remarques sur le sur le
climat et la lutte contre l'effet de
serre il est extrêmement
important de comprendre que nous sommes
dans une nouvelle ère qui s'appelle
l'anthroposain et qui impose de traiter
ensemble les enjeux du changement
climatique et de la réduction de de
l'effet de serre de la santé humaine et
de la biodiversité et il il il il il il
est une aberration par exemple de de
penser qu'on va mieux lutter contre
l'effet de serre en utilisant des
produits qui ont des conséquences
néfastes pour la santé humaine ou pour
la biodiversité merci à Marie pochon
d'avoir rappelé que le Président de la
République euh après euh des mouvements
euh divers sur le statut du glyphosate à
l'échelle française s'était engagé à
porter ce combat à l'échelle européenne
et appelé à une décision
européenne de sortie du glyphosate et
d'avoir rappeler aussi la réalité
c'est-à-dire la puissance des intérêts
économiques des firmes de l'agrochimie
qui sont en cause dans la décision dont
nous débattons Marietta caramanli a
rappelé la problématique du rapport de
l'an de de 2016 je je veux aussi
souligner chers collègues qu'en 2015
lorsque le Centre international de
recherche sur le cancer a classé le
glyphosate comme cancérogène probable en
réalité euh sa décision concernait trois
substance le glyphosate le dianison et
le malation les deux autres ont été
immédiatement sortis dans un délai
proche il n'y a que le glyphosate qui a
été reconnu comme cancérogène probable
par le le cirque qui reste aujourd'hui
autorisé alors que les deux autres il y
a pas eu de débat il y a pas eu de
contestation de leur caractère
cancérogène c'était dans la même
monographie du Centre international de
recherche sur le cancer merci aussi à
Marietta caramanli d'avoir rappelé les
textes des des traités je rappelle à cet
égard que l'article 1er du règlement
européen concernant les pesticides
euh rappelle que l'arrê est celle du
principe de précaution c'est-à-dire que
lorsqu'il y a un débat scientifique sur
les effets d'une substance on doit faire
prévaloir la protection de la santé
humaine et de la
biodiversité madame lepai et j'espère
que je je n'écorche pas votre votre nom
a dit qu'il n'était pas concevable que
les agricultristes et les agriculteurs
supporent le coût des décisions
concernant les substances c'est un point
de vue que je partage
les agricultrices et les agriculteurs
n'ont pas pris la décision d'autoriser
tel ou tel substan ils font avec les
produits qui sont autorisés par les
autorités publiques et les pouvoirs
publics que ce soit en France ou à
l'échelle
européenne ils n'ont donc pas apportter
le le le le le
fardeau il n'y a pas de raison de leur
renvoyer la balle de cette
responsabilité c'est la raison pour
laquelle ma
position ne ne n'a jamais été de dire la
substance reste autorisé et puis il faut
que sur le terrain les agricultrices et
les agriculteurs en sortent si une
substance est dangereuse elle elle doit
être interdite et bien entendu les
changements profonds des pratiques
agricoles qui sont possibles puisque il
y a quand même en France 60000
exploitation en agriculture biologique
qui travaillent sans glyphosate donc
c'est possible dans toutes les
productions agricoles de faire sans
glyphosate doivent être évidemment
puissamment soutenu par les aides de la
politique agricole commune mais aussi
par d'autres dispositions et bien sûr
qu'il y a des questions de transition et
d'accompagnement y compris économique
qui sont absolument nécessaires euh
monsieur fournass a une interprétation
inexacte de la décision du FVP vous
trouverez les citations exactes dans le
rapport euh mais donc les experts du
fond d'indemnisation des victimes des
pesticides se sont bien basés sur
plusieurs études sur les effets
thératogènes des de produits à base de
glyphosate pour prendre la décision et
donc d'un lien possible pour prendre la
décision
d'indemnisation Vous avez ensuite
prétendu que
euh la résolution comme les propos que
j'ai tenu délégitimer la science c'est
exactement l'inverse et d'ailleurs un
abondant et complet rapport de l'opesque
sur ce sujet était extrêmement clair
merci à Julie laernous d'avoir rappelé
les les les
alternatives existantes et pour vous
répondre oui je fais confiance en la
connaissance scientifique
indépendante et et donc non aux
études financé par les industriels qui
ne sont pas accessibles et dont les
données ne sont pas publiques
euh alors ensuite euh il y avait
euh des questions euh sur le coût des
alternatives euh de Monsieur ou Madame
éel pardon madame euh euh je crois que
je l'ai abordé et je voudrais euh
remercier
Sandrine leffur euh de ce qu'elle a
rappelé à la fois sur l'état des
connaissances scientifiques euh sur
l'enjeu éthique et sur les
alternatives
existantes ce qui montre que ce
débat peut traverser l'ensemble de nos
de nos groupes euh en
conclusion je voudrais vous dire que la
France en 2017 avait voté contre et
qu'aujourd'hui elle doit à nouveau voter
contre euh la proposition de la
Commission européenne est parfaitement
inacceptable et on ne peut pas être ni
pour ni contre l'autorisation d'un
poison c'est là la
limite de de de ce qui est ce qui a été
évoqué par certains et certaines d'entre
vous sur les les logiques de restriction
d'usage si un produit pose un problème
on le sort on ne fait pas juste qu'en
réduire un petit peu la quantité
utilisée l'abstention euh de la France à
mon yeux à mes yeux est regrettable et
elle cache une vraie décision la vraie
décision c'est d'être pour le
renouvellement de la substance à mes
yeux l'abstention et le et le V et le
pire vote possible et la France doit
avoir le courage de voter
contre merci beaucoup avant de procéder
au vote il encore une demande de prise
de parole de Monsieur fugi pour 2
minutes
oui merci président juste
me permettre de de de de répondre parce
que un petit peu réponse partielle de
Madame la rapporteur par rapport à ce
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure moi je me
suis permis de rappeler l'historique et
je trouve dommage je le dis très très
très gentiment à Marie pochon comme
rapporteur vous passez complètement sous
silence un certain nombre de choses qui
sont passées entre 2017 2023 on peut ne
pas être d'accord on peut dire ça va
passer vite ça va passer loin mais quand
même passer sous silence qu'on a mis en
place une stratégie de sortie
progressive qui a eu une mission
parlementaire qui a suivi qui a rendu
qui a rendu on complètement passé au
silence en disant 202 23 2027 c'est
exactement la même situation ce n'est
pas vrai ce n'est pas vrai et donc vous
passez sous silence et vous laissez
entendre que en plus nous sommes soumis
à des soumis à des lobis et cetera c'est
assez choquant et c'est assz c'est AZ
contrarien alors on va parler des
chiffres maintenant donc le rapport de
la mission parlementaire 2020 il y a
déjà il est dans le dans le domaine
public et il y a déjà des chiffres
ensuite je viens de me connecter tout
simplement sur le site du ministère
d'agriculture je vous invite à voir le
16 novembre 2022 c'est pas moi données
les données elles vous donnent les
évolutions de toutes les molécules les
CMR et cetera et vous avez le glyphosate
vous avez les chiffres vous avez les
tableaux d'évolution et vous voyez que
il y a moins d'usage du glyphosate donc
en 2021 ou 2022 par exemple par rapport
à 2016 2017 et cetera c'est c'est public
hein c'est sur le site du ministère
c'est pas moi qui voilà je voulais
simplement dire que quand on a
accompagné nos agriculteurs on a bien
pris en compte la question du du coût et
cetera avec notamment le crédit d'impôt
le crédit d'impôt 2500 € que nous avons
voté fin 2020 pour 2021 et 2022 on peut
contester il y a 45 millions d'euros qui
ont été mis sur la table il y a 17000
923 foyers fiscaux qui ont eu agricoles
qui on utilisé ce ce créer d'impôt ne
disons pas qu'on fait rien qu'on
accompagne pas et encore une fois à la
fin notre position à nous au groupe
Renaissance c'est quoi c'est pas on
n'est pas là pour défendre le glyphosate
parce que la manière de vous présenter
les choses c'est donner l'impression que
nous sommes des défenseurs soumis à des
soumis et cetera on dit
laissez-moi laissez-moi finir simplement
pour finir pour finir nous ce qu'on veut
dire c'est que aujourd'hui on veut
sortir progressivement de cette molécule
sauf qu'on peut pas laisser nos
agriculteurs sans solution et donc comme
il y a un problème de technique
culturale qui ne sont pas toujours au
point on ne veut pas remplacer le
glyphosate par une autre molécule ce
serait une aberération en revanche
remplacé par des techniques culturelles
qui permettent de s'en passer à terme
c'est ce qu'il faut faire et c'est déjà
ce qui a été fait partiellement et donc
aujourd'hui notre opposition c'est
d'être opposé à la résolution parce que
vous laissez des agriculteurs sans
solution en revanche sur la durée il va
falloir se poser réellement la question
merci beaucoup la parole est à Henri
Alfandari pour le groupe raison pour
juste un un tout petit mot
euh il faut quand même ne pas oublier
que en grande culture quand on dit pas
de
glyphosate hors agriculture de
conservation ça veut dire une chute
drastique des rendements et si on est et
si
on et aussi c'est plus de passage
mécanique donc forcément étant donné
qu'on se consomme des énergies fossiles
c'est beaucoup plus d'émissions carbone
doncutut faut être clair le principe de
précaution une fois de plus il est il
est à regarder de manière multiim
non non mais écoutez il y a pas ne soyez
pas s'il vous plaît PLA vous pouvezil
vous
PLT pas
pourex sachez
entendre attendez une seconde attendez
une seconde attendez une seconde tous
les groupes tous les groupes ont la
possibilité de reprendre la parole s'il
le souhait c'est un su important donc
que tout le monde que tout le monde se
calme que Monsieur s'exprime et ensuite
madame bateau répondra on aura
terminé risque en grande culture une
fois de plus de de de de forte émission
carbone en plus je crois que vous l'avez
dit à juste titre effectivement
l'agriculture de conservation ça
représente 4 %. mais est-ce que l'enjeu
n'est justement pas une fois de plus
l'évolution des patiques
professionnelles de d'avoir les
meilleures pratiques reproduites un
maximum je je je une fois voilà je je
dis juste que l'enfer est pas avé de
bonnes intentions que regarder cette
question du glyphosate de manière
unidimensionnelle à l'instant T peut
conduire à des catastrophes beaucoup
plus importantes sur beaucoup de sujets
dans notre société souvent on contourne
la réalité des problème alors que la
réalité du problème c'est une évolution
des pratiques professionnelles merci
beaucoup madame
bateau si
bon
alors
donc si la sérénité
euh peut nous permettre
d'aller vers le vote je voudrais dire
pour qu'il n'y ait pas de malentendu à
notre collègue Jean-Luc fugi d'abord
qu'en ce qui concerne les alternatives
je parle d'alternative non chimique je
je ne m'inscris évidemment pas dans la
logique d'une interdiction du glyphosate
pour être remplacé par une molécule qui
qui poserait tout autant problème
surtout je voulais vous préciser que
l'objet de la résolution comme de la
discussion que nous avons n'est pas
d'examiner et de se prononcer sur les
choix qui ont été faits en France et en
politique agricole française entre 2017
et 2023 vous faisiez simplement
référence tout à l'heure à des chiffres
sur lesquels je vous dis que les
chiffres officiels du bnvp qui sont
publiés ne sont pas
aujourd'hui présentés pour l'année 2022
et que par conséquent je vous informais
du fait que j'ai cherché les données sur
l'affirmation de juillet dernier du
ministre de l'Agriculture selon lequel
il y avait une diminution de 27 % des
quantités due au concernant le
glyphosate qui qui est peut-être une
donnée je vous dis simplement que cette
donnée n'est pas n'est pas complète
n'est pas officielle n'est pas en ligne
et que y compris j'ai demandé j'ai
demandé à ce que on nous la communique
il s'agit d'une donnée pour instant
provisoire et les données officielles
définitives n'existent pas
ensuite pour finir
euh écoutez chers
collègues on est pour ou on est
contre
l'abstention l'abstention non on est
pour ou contre le renouvellement de
l'autorisation à l'échelle européenne
les responsables politiques doivent
assumer leur décisions et
s'abstenir dans un contexte où il y a
une montée du populisme dans un contexte
où il y a un une montée du complotisme
le rapport c'est que c'est une manière
pour les responsables politiques de se
dérober à une décision qui un impact sur
la santé humaine qu'un impact sur la
biodiversité et de louvoyer là où
aujourd'hui les citoyennes et les
citoyens sont en droit d'attendre de la
clarté donc soit on est pour le
renouvellement du glyphosate soit on est
contre mais la position actuelle de la
France de s'abstenir n'est pas
acceptable très bien merci Madame la
rapporteur aucun amendement ayant été
déposé je mets au voix la proposition de
résolution qui est
pour qui est contre elle est
rejetée ce qui clos notre discussion en
remerciant madame la rapporteur pour
pour son travail et sa présence
aujourd'hui merci chers collègues